ppe and raw materials that are needed to
manufacture vaccines in india
and cdc has a long history of working
with and in india on public health
measures
we'll be deploying a strike team to the
country to support
the public health efforts there we are
committed to
india through this difficult time
in addition yesterday we announced that
given the strong portfolio
of approved highly effective and safe
vaccines here in the united states
we're looking at the options to share
astrazeneca vaccines
with other countries as they become
available
this should amount to around 60 million
doses
or so over the next two months
the astrazeneca vaccine is highly safe
and effective
and approved in many parts of the world
and said it is not since it is not
approved for use in the u.s
we do not need to use the astrozenica
vaccine here during the next few months
we have sufficient supply of vaccines
from
pfizer moderna and johnson johnson to
accommodate
our needs in the u.s
in closing before i hand it over to dr
welinski
vaccines are now broadly available
accessible and are located within five
miles
of 90 of americans if you were 16 or
above
and have not been vaccinated the scenes
around the world
should help convince you that now is the
time your risk from being
unvaccinated is too high
please make an appointment today and
with that
i will turn it to dr wolinski thank you
and good afternoon and i'm so glad to be
back with you all again today
let's begin with an overview of the data
yesterday
cdc reported over 34 600 cases
of covet 19. our seven day average
is just over 54 400 cases per day
and this represents a really hopeful
decline
of about 21 from our prior seven day
average
the seven day average of hospital
admissions is just over fifty one
hundred
again a positive sign with a decrease of
about nine percent
from the previous seven day period and
the seven day average of daily deaths
also declined about to about 660 per day
a decrease of about six percent
each day more and more americans are
rolling
up their sleeves and getting vaccinated
and likely contributing to these very
positive trends
we regularly share with you the benefits
of vaccination
the efficacy in preventing infection and
the decreases we see
in hospitalizations and deaths these are
incredibly important benefits of
vaccination
and there are so many more i know that
the quarantine and shutdowns throughout
the pandemic
have been exhausting i know that we all
miss the things that we used to do
before the pandemic and i know that we
all want to get back to doing those
things that we love
and soon today another day we
take that back to the normalcy of before
over the past year we have spent a lot
of time telling americans what they
cannot do
they should not do today i'm going to
tell you some of the things
you can do if you are fully vaccinated
again as a reminder the cdc defines
fully vaccinated
as 14 days after your second dose of a
pfizer or modern vaccine
or 14 days after your single dose of a j
j
vaccine today cdc is updating our
recommendations for fully vaccinated
people
and providing guiding principles and
sample activities
to give people who are fully vaccinated
a way to assess their own risk for
covid19
and determine what situations are safe
if you are fully vaccinated things are
much safer for you than those who are
not yet fully vaccinated
this guidance will help you your family
and your neighbors make decisions based
on the latest science
and allow you to safely get back to
things you love to do
i am optimistic that people will use
this information to take
personal responsibility to protect
themselves
and to protect others and i hope will
encourage people
to get fully vaccinated there are many
situations where fully vaccinated people
do not need to wear a mask particularly
if they are outdoors
as shown by the graphic on the right if
you are fully vaccinated and want to
attend a small
outdoor gathering with people who are
vaccinated and
unvaccinated or dying at an outdoor
restaurant with friends from multiple
households
the science shows if you are vaccinated
you can do so safely unmasked
on the cdc website we have posted
examples of numerous
outdoor activities that are safe to do
without
a mask if you are fully vaccinated
generally for vaccinated people outdoor
activities without a mask are safe
however
we continue to recommend masking in
crowded
outdoor settings and venues such as
packed
stadiums and concerts where there is
decreased ability to maintain
physical distance and where many
unvaccinated people
may also be present we will continue to
recommend this until widespread
vaccination
is achieved now let's talk about what
you can do
indoors here again we have unvaccinated
people
and their risk on the left where nothing
has changed
risk is indicated and masking is
required
we then show the markedly decreased risk
for vaccinated people
on the right given what we know about
covid19 vaccines and their efficacy
it is also safe for those who are fully
vaccinated to return to the activities
they love
doing inside while wearing a mask
the guiding principles we release today
and the illustrative examples compare
the safety of several activities
if you are vaccinated or not and the
difference
is clear as we gather more and more data
on the real world efficacy of vaccines
we know that masked fully vaccinated
people
can safely attend worship services
inside
go to an indoor restaurant or bar and
even participate
in an indoor exercise class although
these vaccines are extremely effective
we know that the virus spreads very well
indoors
until more people are vaccinated and
while we still have more than
50 000 cases a day mask use
indoors will provide extra protection
the examples today show that when you
are fully vaccinated
you can return to many activities safely
and most of them outdoors and unmasked
and begin
to get back to normal and the more
people who are vaccinated
the more steps we can take towards
spending time with
people we love doing the things we love
to enjoy
i hope this message is encouraging for
you it shows
just how powerful these vaccines are in
our efforts to end this pandemic
and why we are asking everyone to roll
up their sleeves and get vaccinated
the science is clear the covid19
vaccines have been through
many transparent rigorous processes that
continue to prove
they are safe and effective if you
haven't already
please get vaccinated in some
communities you can find walk-up venues
who have advanced appointments
or wherever appointments aren't even
necessary
to see more details about what we
release today including the evidence and
science behind these recommendations
and to learn more about the activities
you can safely do when you are fully
vaccinated
please go to cdc.gov thank you and i'll
now turn things over to dr fauci
thank you very much dr belinsky i'd like
to spend just the next couple of minutes
talking about the subject of variance
and the role of vaccination and
protecting against variants can i have
the first slide please
so we're going to look at evidence from
clinical trials
and when they're not available from
laboratory studies
as well as real-world experience to
indicate a degree of protection
against variants of interest or concern
next slide
here is a list very familiar to you
of a number of the variants that are in
play
throughout the world and in the united
states next slide
so let's go quickly through them and
make one or two comments
to inform where we are first the b117
the original
uk variant which now has assumed the
dominance
in the united states next slide it is
very clear now
that this particular variant is covered
very well
by the mrna vaccines as well as
by the astrazeneca novovax and others as
shown by
data from israel on the right in which
the dominant 117 predominates
there and as you can see as the vaccine
doses increase
the cases come down similarly in the
united kingdom
using other vaccines you see the same
situation
this is good news since this is the
dominant variant next slide
the next slide is the one that's the
most problematic the south african
variant which is certainly not dominant
here but
is in south africa and other locations
throughout the world
next slide the data we have i presented
at a former conference
as you can see the j j is 64
efficacious the novovax 60
the astrogenica not so good of note
pfizer did a small study in which they
looked at the effect
in south africa and they found that as a
matter of fact
it was a hundred percent effective the
caveat here is still a very
small study but note the j and j
that even though it was 64 effective
in south african study there were
virtually no
deaths or hospitalizations so although
the efficacy went down
for moderate disease there was good
protection
against serious disease next slide
then we have the p1 the one that is
right now
ravaging brazil next slide
we know from studies now that there's
variable protection
in real world effectiveness namely
things
that were not done necessarily in a
clinical trial
in brazil it was 50 effective
after a single dose they went on to a
second dose
and that stayed at approximately 50
percent
this was under the condition where 75
of the cases were p1
rather similar results from chile a
little bit better
with 7 67 effective
versus symptomatic disease 14 days after
the second dose
next slide now returning to the united
states
the california variant 429-427
next slide here we have mostly in vitro
data and by in vitro data we mean
we take the antibodies that are induced
by vaccines in this case mrna
and we determine their ability to
neutralize
the given variance in the test tube
and as you can see there's a slight to
modest loss
here of about two to three fold this
is not likely going to be relevant from
a clinical standpoint
since there's a considerable cushion in
the antibodies
induced by this vaccine next slide
and then we have the 526 which was
originally the new york and spreading in
certain areas
in the new york city metropolitan area
next slide
here too we rely on in vitro data
with a moderate loss about three to five
times
of neutralizing activity from the mrna
again
this is still within the cushion that
you would see
protected since the antibodies induced
by this vaccine are considerably high
and then finally next slide we have
the troublesome india 617
next slide now this is something where
we're still
gaining data on a daily basis
but the most prelim the most recent data
was looking at convalescent cira
of cover 19 cases and people who
received
the vaccine used in india the covexin
and it was found to neutralize the 617
variant so despite the real difficulty
that we're seeing in india vaccination
could be a very
very important antidote against this
so i'll stop there with the final
statement the one thing you can gather
from everything i've said
that it's very important to get
vaccinated
so as dr wolenski said even when you're
talking
about variants indoors outdoors
get vaccinated and you will certainly
have a degree of protection
i'll hand it back to you andy thank you
okay let's go to questions
thanks andy unite i know a lot of people
have questions today so please keep your
question to one question let's go to
aaron billups at spectrum news
hi thanks for taking my question uh can
you guys uh
explain the science behind the guidance
change at this moment is the
understanding that there are enough
americans
fully vaccinated to sufficiently slow
the spread of coronavirus outdoors
that the likelihood of transmission
outdoors is very low and what about
pockets of the country that have not yet
reached
national levels of vaccination should
the guidance be different
for areas with lower vaccine vaccination
rates
mike thank you there's increasing data
that suggests that
most of transmission is happening
indoors rather than outdoors less than
10 percent of documented transmission
and many studies have occurred
outdoors we also know that there's a
almost a 20-fold
increased risk of transmission in the
indoor setting in the outdoor
setting that coupled with the fact that
we now have 30
30 uh seven percent of people over the
age of 18
fully vaccinated and the fact that our
case rights are now starting to come
down
motivated our change in guidance as
noted this is the third time we've
changed our guidance um
in fully vaccinated people and as more
people get vaccinated and as case rights
continue to come
down we will come up with further
updates
next question caitlin collins cnn
thank you very much uh my question given
this new guidance
should states that have outdoor mask
requirements
change those to reflect this new
guidance
is that is that your advice for those
states and those governors
what we're saying is uh states that have
mass requirements
outdoors if people are vaccinated we no
longer feel that the vaccinated people
require masks outdoors so to the extent
that those are consistent
i do want to sort of convey this outdoor
large public venue
such as uh as concerts stadiums and
things like that and a lot of that is
the the inability to distinguish between
vaccinated and unvaccinated and to say
that in those settings
when you have those at that density we
really do worry about protecting the
unvaccinated people
next question
ariel hart at the atlanta journal
constitution
hi i'd like to go back to the question
about
um for states that do not have yet
national
rate that are below average uh should
there be different guidance for us
i'm calling from georgia
i think the general guidance to ensure
people are getting vaccinated
and um we do know that if you are
vaccinated it is safe to be outdoors
without a mask
and the general can the general guidance
is
the more and more people who get
vaccinated the safer the more you'll
have
more people who are safer without masks
so um get vaccinated and if you are then
it's safe to be outside without a mass
next question kristen welker nbc
hi everyone thank you so much um firstly
can you address if the risk of being
outdoors
is so low why doesn't this guidance
apply to everyone
and secondly while rates of vaccine
hesitancy
are dropping you still have about four
in ten americans who say
maybe or no they're not going to get the
vaccine
how do you deal with that hesitancy are
there any new strategies that you're
looking for
dr wolinski um you know
we still believe as people are in small
gatherings medium-sized
gatherings when they are unvaccinated
you're at risk you have people who are
at risk of severe disease so we do
believe in those settings
masks should still occur certainly any
activity
is is less risky when you have more
ventilation
more space between people more people
wearing masks if they're unvaccinated
but again i'd go back to the primary
principles
of being outdoors in general and wearing
masks until
outdoors until you have a vaccine um
uh the second question was
vaccine hesitancy that vaccine hesitancy
numbers are dropping but
it's still significant i just had a
conversation with someone yesterday
who said they weren't going to get the
vaccine i said why this person said
because i need more information
how do you get to those people who are
still skeptical
yeah we're spending an extraordinary
amount of effort through our community
course and doing this
outreach we knew that we were going to
um first vaccinate everybody who was
rolling up their sleeves immediately and
wanting it and then we were going to
have to do the work of meeting people
where they are understanding their
reasons for
for not wanting to get vaccinated and
really explaining
is it about the science um is it that
you felt that the science was too fast
we believe and know that the science
moved
um quickly we've enrolled in a hundred a
hundred thousand people in these trials
um and the science stood on the
shoulders of years and years of work
before to be able to deliver these
vaccines dr fauci has previously talked
about that
if people are worried about the side
effects we can convey the data of
over 200 million vaccine doses delivered
and the safety that
and the scrutiny of that safety so we
really need to meet people where they
are and understand
why they might be hesitant and then give
them the information that combats that
hesitancy
yeah dr fauci anything you want to add
about the development of these vaccines
over the last couple decades
well yeah i mean as dr wolinski said
we try to go step by step of what is it
about the situation that makes you
hesitant
and one of them is in fact the speed
with which this has happened because
we've been talking for a long time
that vaccines usually take years to go
from a recognition of the pathogen to
getting vaccine into people's arms we
did it in 11
months but as we've said often that is a
reflection of
decades of scientific advances in two
major areas
one vaccine platform technology which
led
for the years of work to perfect the
mrna
and the vector such as the adenovector
approach
and secondly structure-based vaccine
design
that led to the precise correct
confirmation
of the spike protein which proved to be
so immunogenic
and in fact got translated into a highly
efficacious
vaccine you're talking about decades
of fundamental science when people hear
that
they realize that this was not being
rushed
that they are benefiting from the
culmination of years of research
kristin i think one thing that we're
cognizant of and always have been
is everyone has their own decision
making process some people decide
quickly some people take a little bit
more time to decide
i think it's important that we respect
everybody's decision making process and
the person that you spoke about
our advice to them is talk to your
doctor talk to your pharmacist
talk to people you trust talk to people
who've taken the vaccine
and i think the picture that emerges is
130 million americans hundreds millions
more overseas
significant differences in their safety
and the risk of these uh effect of these
viruses particularly the variants
is just too high so as more people do
their own homework
we'll give them the time and the
information and the local resources
through the community core to do that
homework and
we think that is what is responsible for
moving more people in that direction
next question sheryl stollberg new york
times
thank you for doing this call this is
for dr walensky um
dr wolinski you talk about small and
medium-sized gatherings but
you don't define what they are so i'm
wondering can you please define for
people what a small and medium-sized
gathering
is or say why you don't aren't defining
it if there's some reason for that
and then separately you talked a few
weeks ago about feeling a sense of
impending doom
and i wonder if you could reflect on
that and
talk a little bit more about how you
feel right now given the numbers
thank you for that question cheryl you
know the what i'll get back to is the
basic
concepts because if we define a small
and medium-sized gathering we actually
also have to define the size of the
space that it's in
the um ventilation that is occurring the
space between
people and so we're um i think we should
get back to the the
general concepts small and medium-sized
gatherings for people who are
outside and vaccinated can safely be
done without a mask
but we really do want um people who are
uh unvaccinated to limit the interaction
with people and to go back to the basic
principles of increased ventilation and
increased spacing uh for any given size
um you know several weeks ago when i had
this feeling of impending doom and i and
i
articulated that and i had um you know
case races going rates going up
vaccine uh vaccinations growing but not
where we needed to be
and and deaths continuing to climb as i
look at the curve now it's stabilizing
it's coming down um the vaccinations
have continued to grow
um in an extraordinary way i think we
really do need to get
more and more people vaccinated um as
kristin noted we need to sort of
combat the hesitancy that is out there
meet people where we where they
are and encourage everyone to get
vaccinated um
but as i see more vaccines uh getting
into people's arms more and more people
being willing to do so confidence
increasing
and then i match that with the cases
that are starting to
stabilize plateau and come down as well
as dr
fauci's slides that demonstrate when the
other countries have been a little bit
ahead of us and
shown that when those vaccinations
continue to soar in the cases comment
that we should be in good shape next
question
zeke ap
thanks for uh for doing this um doctor
once you guys hope you can clarify a
little bit why
are the people who are fully vaccinated
wearing masks and all of those different
scenarios is it to protect
others from uh from them in case they
have a breakthrough infection does it
protect themselves from potentially
acquiring infection infection
infection or is it to model safe
behavior for those who are not
vaccinated around them
um in all of those spaces and also do
you have any targets by which you would
sort of begin to
roll back you know how many people need
to be vaccinated in society for you to
begin
you know allowing people to wear masks
at baseball to
take their masks off to baseball
stadiums or indoor dining or the like
yeah thank you maybe i'll tackle that
first question for that second question
first and that is i think some of these
targets have to be the interplay of the
number of people vaccinated in the
number of cases that we're seeing
and it's that intersection that i think
is going to be important
i think that part of um one of the
things that we need to look
at is the lack of uniformity of
vaccination rates across
the country it was previously brought up
not every state not every county is
vaccinating at the same rate and where
we have low areas of vaccination we are
going to potentially see more outbreaks
which is why i think it's really we have
to be careful and we have to make sure
that people get vaccinated in all
corners and in all counties with regard
to
why people who are vaccinated are
wearing masks
indoors um i think what we really need
to convey
here is we still have 50 000 cases a day
we do believe that vaccinated people are
much safer when they're wearing those
masks and doors as indicated by the
green on the right side of that graphic
and right now it's very hard to
uh to tease apart who is vaccinated
where they are in the vaccination
so it's not just to protect themselves
but largely to protect others and really
to protect the unvaccinated
all right next question let's go to
stephanie abs at abc
um thank you i wanted to ask about a
different topic actually the
the reports that the pentagon is
tracking 14 cases
of heart inflammation or myocarditis
among
service members and families people who
were vaccinated through
the the military health care system can
you tell us any more about those cases
and and what
cdc knows or maybe what dr fauci can
tell us about
any potential relationship to
vaccination
so maybe first we'll go to dr walensky
if you have any familiarity
no um yeah i'm aware of those reports i
i don't necessarily want to comment on
what the dod is doing and investigating
in their own investigations what i will
say is we've delivered
over 200 million doses of vaccine
of these vaccines and after hearing
about these reports we
again looked back in our vaccine safety
data and we had not seen any reports of
those those have since been reported
to us and so those investigations are
ongoing
but um you know it is a it is a
different demographic than we normally
see
and we will be working with dod to
understand what is happening
in those 14 cases we have not seen the
signal and we've actually looked
intentionally for the signal
in the over 200 million doses we've
given so not enough data yet
early okay next question
all right we've got time for one more
question let's go to anjali kimlani at
yahoo
thank you so much really quickly can you
walk us through the timeline of the
aid being sent to india specifically
first on the
uh ventilators and protective gear and
oxygen and then secondly on the vaccine
doses when you anticipate those will be
sent
out yeah i mean we're beginning to move
uh immediately i can't give you the
exact timing on each of those pieces
but we're in constant contact with the
indian government and the indian health
authorities
as i think i mentioned earlier we have a
cdc team
that's headed over to india to help
coordinate this response
in terms of in terms of vaccines as i
mentioned
uh earlier we are in a position now
where we can foresee
that we will not be using uh the
astrazeneca doses that we expect to come
online
uh i want to be to be clear that we no
none of those doses
are yet made available based upon fda
inspection so once that's done as soon
as that happens
we will have 10 million doses available
those will be
distributed globally and then we expect
over the next couple of months another
50 million
you know this is of course in addition
to many of the strategies that dr fauci
myself jeff and others have talked about
um for
supplying the globe with additional um
vaccines and additional vaccination
efforts through kovacs
and finally i think you may be aware
that we are um
making sure that we are locating some of
the raw materials necessary
to create more vaccines in india which i
think is going to be
an important help there so with that i'm
going to come and bring this to a close
thank you for all your questions and
we'll be here doing this briefing again
on friday
you